the stars of hardcore pawn' will tell
you that a story comes with every item
that passes through their shops doors
and they're not kidding only a small
fraction of those stories actually makes
it on the air however the rest are left
on the cutting room floor to later be
dusted off and presented here less gold
once owned dr. kevorkians van in one of
the more morbid transactions in pawnshop
entertainment history American Jewelry
and Loan once purchased dr. Jack
kevorkians van according to the New York
Daily News
Kevorkian performed about 130 assisted
suicides in the 1968 Volkswagen minibus
which less gold bought from a scrapyard
in 1997 for $20,000 gold then owned the
death mobile as it's known for almost 20
years until he sold it for a $5,000
profit in 2014 because it took up too
much room amazingly gold sold the van to
another reality TV show star zak bagans
from Ghost Adventures spooky coincidence
or a reality TV synergy Seth gold man of
the people in December 2014
Michigan State Senators wanted to
introduce a bill that allowed pawnshops
to increase the interest they charged on
fond items by 20% for a month while this
sounds like something shop owners would
support wholeheartedly Seth gold of
American Jewelry and Loan actually
opposed the measure our business is
predicated on people with getting their
stop back redeeming their merchandise in
fact on a national average
82 9% of all customers that get loans
with us to get the merchandise back you
stretch that interest rate make it
higher while the default rates going to
explode
fortunately for Gold's customers it
seems the bill never actually became a
law they're Patriots
according to Detroit's WDIV news back in
2012 Les and Seth helped the US Secret
Service nab Kenny boom Smith who
attempted to sell some bogus
hundred-dollar bills and a
counterfeiting machine to the famous
pawn shop even more ridiculous Smith's
signed a waiver to appear on the show
it's unlikely that Smith has a future in
television except maybe an appearance on
cops
Ashley Gould broad runs an honest shop
in an interview with a Las Vegas Sun
Ashley Gould broad told a story from a
few years earlier when a woman came into
the shop asking $100 for a bag of stones
broad looked through the bag and found a
Burmese Ruby which a certified
gemologist appraised at $10,000 rather
than take advantage of her find brought
did the honest thing and gave the woman
10 grand while some would see that as an
amazingly kind gesture broad insists
it's just good business
they have celebrity clientele so
American Jewelry alone may not have
hundreds of celebs stepping through
their doors every day but the one that
can be verified is impressive according
to the Detroit Free Press Breaking Bad's
Erin Paul once visited the store in
search of a gold bar with an inscription
reading yeah branch of the event Ashley
gold broad said I'm able to accommodate
a lot of people at the shop but that one
didn't happen sorry Jessie one episode
has a tragic PostScript American Jewelry
and Loan may not be the safest place to
visit
even by pawnshop standards Detroit
resident David Kaczynski who made a
memorable appearance on the show in 2013
was killed two years later in a
confrontation with police
according to reports Kappas insky failed
to obey verbal orders from officers
called to his apartment during a
domestic disturbance which resulted in
repeated tasering kappa since keys
girlfriend claims it was a
misunderstanding and told reporters that
the thick-headed barato he displayed on
the show was just part of a setup for
the series why are they always in the
same clothes ever wonder why the main
cast of the show is often seen wearing
the same outfit on air well according to
an April 2016 a.m. a chat with Les and
Seth gold on reddit and has less to do
with being clueless to today's trends
and more to do with continuity les
revealed quote I have 12 of the white
sweaters at least we wear the same
clothing day-to-day for continuity
purposes on the
show and put the same apparently applies
to Seth who he says only has one outfit
too
unscripted over the years many reality
TV shows have been accused of or exposed
as being fake what about hardcore pawn'
if Seth is to be believed the show is
100% real saying during the AMA quote
we're pawnbrokers not actors the truth
is these are real customers also the
stuff you see us buy on the show you can
see that it's real too because we have
things you've seen on the show for sale
on our showroom floor end quote thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one
you just saw and leave us a comment to
let us know which hardcore pawn' fact
surprised you the most